I don't like this I don't like this Bank
collapse and I and because I have a
little bit of money now so what I want
the poor to do if this happens behave
please
because I know the poor and they are
good people but they will start
and what we're asking you to do
please is just watch the Netflix
if they won't let you get the money out
of your account just watch the goddamn
Netflix
don't go out into the street and try to
kill me when I'm in my Bentley which is
from 2018.
it's not even new it's not even new
don't pull me out of that kill me
because you have issues what you have to
do is watch the Netflix if it all goes
because they have how
many grams do they have on that it's
unending how many programs they have on
Netflix you will get food we will give
you food calm down you're gonna get food
it'll be bugs
but bugs are good they're crunchy like
cookies
what's on Netflix there are 36 000 hours
to go through sit and watch Netflix
don't take to the streets
please behave
behave
please God it's perfect weather for this
too I wish this was the dead of Summer
I wish this was the dead of Summer this
is perfect Springtime weather for a
fight this is like the Arab Spring we
could have it in America please be Eve
just relax
don't kill me kill the others they have
more
they have more I'm telling you they have
more I'll show you where they live
watch the Netflix eat the can of pasta
you get
we will give you a can of pasta eat it
share it with the children
and pray get God again time for God
can of Pasta Plus God equals good life
killing me not nice
that's not right I'm in this balenciago
D but we're over this right we know
they're rapists but they make free acts
get someone else to make three acts I'll
throw it out
I'm telling you right now just please
behave don't go nuts out there I know
they're gonna go nuts I can feel it this
is what's gonna happen they're gonna
Monday they're gonna go to the ATM and
his money's not gonna come out and they
are going to it's gonna be bad
but I would like you at that moment when
the money doesn't come out of the ATM I
want you to go huh
go back to your home
because we are sending care packages
they will be sent to you the government
will provide for you you will get a can
of pasta you will get a bag of cake
a bag of sugar cake for the kids
now this is my this could be my last
plea it might be my last book I didn't
know I'd be rich I'm 38 years old I had
no money my whole life I was a fat
failure my whole life from when I was
[__] nine till now I only have a
little bit of money now a little bit of
money now and it's not even enough money
it's a it's enough money to take a 22
year old out to dinner and go here's
salmon ooh there's your penis it's not
even a lot of body it's a little bit of
money please don't kill me when you see
me in Beverly Hills stay out of Beverly
Hills please please stay out of Beverly
Hills it's not right
I made money in a few years the years
and years of nothing and no money and
now I'm the enemy and I know you will
hate me it's not my fault
it's not my fault these classes are
these aren't worth maybe eight eight
hundred thousand dollars
[Laughter]
I'm kidding they were 1100 I know it's
disgusting I know it's your rent I know
it's your rent I don't know what to do
for you I'm sorry I believe you should
have health care I've always said that
in a clinic that's separate from me but
they're like overcrowded I don't want to
smell you and see your problems I'm just
saying when this happens on Monday and
can you please relax a little bit and
behave
that's all I'm asking I'm just asking it
because I just have money for the last
couple of years that's it so long I was
one of you at one point waiting for the
can of pasta in my hovel thinking of
eating my fam I understand that
but I don't listen I just we you know I
got a middle of money on the internet
it's not a big deal so I just want
everyone to behave and relax because I
God I think it's coming and I just don't
it's not fair Now give me a couple of
years please Christ almighty enough
bring up some articles is this is this
even gonna happen maybe I'm overstating
it God I hope I am
why don't we come up with people to kill
so but so that it's not me we can get
people that really deserve people that
have so much more money than me and I
will help you how many how many people
took their money out of Chase
how many people took their money out of
Chase that's always a good indicator
because chases they you know Jamie
Diamond says it's a vault and what he
means by that is it's a vault of all the
Epstein tapes but it it's still a vault
and uh but people are saying go to that
guy Guantanamo Bay on Twitter he's he's
great he just tweets about Marxism and
911 all day but it's fun you know I like
someone that commits I like a theme and
um he really does he just does deep
Dives on CIA figures that were involved
in in 911 but he's he's posing these
really interesting articles about the
banking class and Peter Schiff I mean
God is Peter Schiff he's probably got a
24-hour erection he's been predicting
this collapse for years and it's finally
here the banks are going to evaporate
it's a liquidity crisis the FED cannot
lower the interest rates to zero it
would you know it's all over now and all
I'm asking on behalf of people that have
made money in the last three years is
that you remember that there are people
that have had money for a very very very
very very very long time kill them
that's all I'm asking
if you I I will help you I will help you
do you want to start a podcast this is a
good time to start a podcast you can do
it I will help you so I'm just saying
don't kill me I know that it feels like
the right thing to do and I in your
shoes might kill me too but there's a
lot of good things coming your way if
you behave can of pasta open it yummy
time a bag of cake it won't be a cake
it'll be cake cake bits we'll call them
cake comes it's just easier to deliver
and you can put your hand in it and
it'll be like coffee Crumbs from a crumb
cake but with Funfetti sprinkles then
you could just you'd throw it at the
kids and the kids are going nuts with
the Funfetti it's gonna be fine it's
gonna be okay we're gonna give you a
smoothie you're gonna get a smoothie for
your bones strong but and you're gonna
be allowed out of the house for for a
good amount of time to get the exercise
but what we can't have is violent mobs
in the street asking for my Bentley from
2018. it's not going to help you it's
from 2018 it's not even that good
um so that that's my whole thing my
whole thing is like
um you know I just I just want everyone
to behave that's all that's all I'm
asking for you can get mad at me you can
get offended I'm just saying I've only
had money for a couple of years I used
to hang out in these really poor places
where I would do drugs when I was a
child and people would do crazy heinous
things and I you know that was the
majority of my life I was a junkie from
when I was 12 or 13 years old till 25
just drugs alcohol you know and then
from 25 to 35 it was basically just
stand-up comedy and working and then
from you know 35 to 38 which is what I
am now we've made a little bit of money
but that's certainly I am certainly not
the person to kill in this situation
there are like Chelsea Handler Chelsea
Handler has more money than me she has a
lot more money than me I'm not saying
kill her but I'm saying if there's a
this is a hierarchy okay